очень приятно очень много слышал о вас
от кожи и пола и в общем-то очень
приятно познакомиться и с вашим методом
и совсем ее книжку вашу прочла с большим
удовольствием и где вы живете я живу в
киеве в киеве ни печали не стив можно
быть я пару слов скажу представлю просто
ярослава да я буквально пару слов
ярославу удивительный человек во первых
она мой преподаватель итальянского
именно слова и я подтягивался в
итальянский кроме того и росла вы
искусствовед и она читает лекции по
искусству
у него была очень увлекательная работа
когда она помогала итальянским семьям
усыновлять детей из украины и в общем то
в процессе она также выучила итальянский
кроме того ярослава была так любезна что
согласилась
преподавать в нашей школе икигай по
потому методу стив вот поэтому ей очень
интересно я попросил ее прочесть книжку
далее гвоздь и что не сделала вот но
собственно это основной я думаю ярослава
дальше сама скажет ну что нам наследует
нам сказать какая тема сегодня чтобы
люди которые мы смотрели узнали стив ты
предлагал поговорить о если как это
по-русски сказать maintaining
участвовать в малых языках которые не
особо пользуются такой популярностью как
скажем там английский и китайский
немецкий французский на есть
красивых интересных языков которые но не
столь популярны и
как не больше можно что ли плетнев
привлечь внимание людей и как побудить
их больших изучать вот это мы могли бы
сегодня обсудить
но я думаю что когда мы сказать что я
сейчас никогда не не слушаю не говорю
по-русски поэтому может быть немножко
сложно для меня выразить свое мнение по
русски но конечно когда мы скажем
по-английски но родиной modis иногда мы
думаем данным по языки например канаде
французские меньшинства украине в
украине существует два скажем
меньшинства это это это нет но я думаю и
существует испании каталонский
который внутри испания то меньшинства но
в каталонии то большинства то но и мои
меня это например глинкина из самой попы
нами языке то английский потом я не знаю
испанский конечно в сша испанский потому
французский немецкий русский корейский и
японский полянский но существует
языки так я не знаю как финский кто
будет изучать финский части я изучал
части потому что мои родители родился
родилась романовский империя
проблема состоит в том что очень сложно
искать
содержание искать не знаю блин я
использую и книжки и позже пакость
использую нашли x на youtube случае
например случая российского языка много
много о книге много много литературы 19
19 века который бесплатно я могу им
попивать налей очень много очень много
ресурсов
но сейчас на меня например арабский
сложны поэтому проблем с языки и которые
не является так популярно это нет иногда
люди не знают зачем надо изучать языки
это тоже будет без проблем за язык языки
которые говорят много людей но русский
арабский
но и не огрести все весь мир хочет
изучать английский и это меня это этажа
жарко потому что каждый язык
интересно каждый язык имеет свои история
своей
является проблем но я думаю что будет ну
скажем легче начать искать ресурсов
языки
которые говорятся меньше итальянский
например в общем-то не совсем относятся
dark меньшинство но тем не менее
приходят очень часто люди которые уже
знают английский уже знают немецкий и
все равно ну вот случай итальянским мне
кажется меньше всего проблем потому что
все люди приходят так или иначе через
культуру через там кто-то побывал в
италии или кто-то что-то увидел это
архитектура это картины это песни очень
сильно и я сталкиваюсь всегда когда
первые уроки когда я знакомлюсь с
учениками раньше я работала в группах
сейчас вот индивидуально я всегда
спрашиваю почему вы начинаете учить язык
и как правило 90 процентов отвечают
потому что нам нравится то есть любовь к
языку люблю видеть вот это здание мы
хотим узнать мы хотим побывать и
пообщаться и очень мало но тот кто учит
по работе ну вот эта проблема потому что
люди не всегда любят то что они учат и
нужно тоже искать какие-то подходы для
того чтобы заставить их не то что
заставить а привить им вот эту любовь
это же искать какие-то пути для того
чтобы в них открылась эта любовь к языку
[музыка]
думаю когда мы начинаем изучать любой
язык это процесс это не только тот факт
что один прекрасный день мы будем
говорить по я не знаю итальянский но
процесс изучения а я очень
привлекательно иногда что кончится мне
никогда не кончится но но процесс когда
мы начинаем ничего не понимаем ничего не
мем мем сказать и потом полем ночью
понимаем и мы можем что-то сказать и
потом очень долго времени когда у нас
ощущение что никого не какой прогресс
нет и потом потом один день мы слушаем
подключим аудиокнигу и понимаем прогресс
очень какой-либо язык
ну это вот это очень вселяют очень
привязан в человека и все равно вот мне
очень нравится вот это сравнение
изучения языка ваши как путешествие
потому что это она никогда не
заканчивается и когда там люди
спрашивают а вот когда мы уже выучим
чтобы говоря когда мы выучим вот как
чтобы уже все чтобы жить дальше игры
такого невозможно потому что ты все
время открываешь что-то новое и если
сначала ты чуть-чуть говоришь потом чуть
чуть побольше и уже если в человеке
появляется этот интерес и заказов кто
нужно начинать самый читатель искать и
действительно счастья и я думаю что
иногда школах когда изучение вечно
грамматика немножко больше чем надо и
это сложно когда у нас нет опыта сложно
сложно понимать сложно помнить
грамматики поэтому надо надо надо иметь
опыт 95 процентов наше время мы
используем для изучения грамматика или
4 грамоты и это хватит ну и потом это
еще можно скажем до коляскам языке это
можно по началу делать незаметно
поскольку фонетика у нас простая
достаточно то с самого первого занятия
мы начинают говорить и они не заметно
ниже да то есть прям не объясняешь вроде
как сразу не говоришь нам это глагол но
как то люди сразу не проявляли привыкают
и думают испытывать восторг от того что
они сразу на первом же занятии могут
спросить как тебя зовут там узнать как
дела и тихонечку ты даешь вот эти
маленькие кусочки и в итоге получается
что когда чек подходит уже к вопросу о
том а что такое он уже знаете что такое
глаголы что такое прилагательное и так
далее но и но я думаю все равно глаголы
русский продано это нужно это нужно
знать это конечно но иногда когда я
читаю книги английский английский
объяснения есть грамматическими это
ужасно ужасно и случае например японский
и китайский китайский видение грамматика
нет это очень просто язык и там они
начинают за объяснение игры и
технический термин и
это все делать все сложные чем нужно и
конечно надо читать и слышать и
и забудет и потом опять
изучать и опять же будет и по немножку .
все что скажем мясные
ну просто очень многие люди
сталкиваешься с тем что они пытаются
сопротивляться вычитайте как мы можем
читать если мы не знаем что это значит
мы не можем за каждым словом весь
словарь с очень тяжело и и и они куда к
школьные
. метод обучения конечно портит портит
людей потому что ему нужно чтобы вот они
понимали все слова в предложения и
только тогда как это сразу читать как
это сразу слушать ну вот потихоньку и и
очень трудно вот этот характер и да вот
уже характера в изучения языка
немножечко повернуть другую сторону
потому что то что они привыкли там
двенадцать лет школе учится потом еще
пять лет или шесть в институте одно и то
же то есть вот перевод чтение чтения
перевод очень мало используется такой с
более свободны погружением язык поэтому
конечно очень тяжело но все равно мне
кажется что главный интерес в этом когда
появляется это все человек испытывает к
то свободу внутри мен да и и я думаю что
понимание комплимент ли это самое-самое
важное сама важно и когда
как сейчас я попробую говорить по-русски
единого счета
ошибок это неважно и когда мы me
если я буду сейчас и я попробовал прежде
чем начинать наш разговор я слышу нашими
не stories блинки до по-русски и я
заметил что каждый раз когда но например
русские есть проблемы и и когда я слушаю
я замечу вещей который я не заметил
песни
то значит когда вы когда мы не
используем язык
мы будем хуже это это обязательно потому
что надо надо тренировать надо
использовать язык окей сейчас я не
говорю по русски
стал хуже немножко но когда я опять
читать или слушать я заметил вещи
я не знаю победе форм фразе который я не
заметил то значит мы знаем что мы не
можем что-то изучать сейчас я буду
изучать себе победе по-русски потом все
проблем будет вечером это не так мы
изучаем мы забудем мы делаем ошибки
потом заново начинаем и забудет и потом
изучать это очень сильный способ изучать
дальше это лучше чем питаться что-то
жировать это не функционирует хочет
погулять и потом опять и потом конечно
важно тоже
чтобы у каждого был свой интерес потому
что когда есть интерес когда человеку
например что-то очень нравится там
например ему нравится итальянская музыка
например у меня сейчас учится две певицы
для оперных певиц и
и конечно для них очень важно понимать о
чём они поют правильно и с одной стороны
до но понимают и они теперь понимаем о
чем мы поем и они тоже уже сами начинают
их больше музыки слушать и
и в принципе у них вроде как это и
профессиональный интерес и в то же время
они обогащаются за счет того что
какое-то слово они уже знают где его
встречали и так далее то есть они уже
разговаривают они просто могут перевести
слова песни или арии меня например да но
я думаю это очень важный цели изучаете
музыка об и иногда я думаю что очень
важно что прошедший учить
умеет искать или
стимулировать например когда я у меня
дочь значит они говорят только
по-английски но у меня
университет и он делать так что я очень
французский brown
я думаю что это очень важно если вы
человек нет мотивации но и он или она не
умеет искать или
мотивация негатива я не хочу иногда
если учитель стимулируете и искать или
дать ему это важные чем объяснить
кровать конечно ну в любом случае
поэтому учитель должен интересоваться
учениками то есть это взаимный процесс а
у нас очень часто да ну как бы вот
пришел от считал и ушел к с ними не
важно но когда ты интересуешься учеником
ты знаешь его интересы какие-то и да то
что ему нравится и пытаешься как-то
дергать тоже за эти ниточки давать ему
или например признались что этот человек
ну не то чтобы он не любит писать
сочинения но у него не получается но
сначала но зато хорошо там слушает и
понимает на слух и конечно тут даешь ему
больше на слух потом все равно он идет
через это вид а теперь на слух запиши
слова песни которые ты услышал то все
равно как-то каким-то образом можно
выводить тогда человек она интересна и
на на то что он себе этот интерес
обнаружит то что очень часто люди
приходят они не понимают они не знают у
них им надо нам надо по работе не
движется я думаю что это общество
который мы можем общаться через интернет
с людей который любит любит изучать
языки например человек в украине изучает
итальянский или всегда учит или учиться
ты что же учиться тоже итальянский
я знаю через интернет я понять я понять
которые живут в грузии
изучает грузии я рассказал тебе стив я
думаю это в это фантастически потому что
каждый язык и и и у каждой из качество
грузинский украинцы изучаю арабские и
персидские и у меня мая ощущение мая
понимания robe robin человек история
больше бочек
конечно я начну изучать и или читать и
по-английски и стоя и все это дать дают
нам много много изучение
какой-либо язык не только английский для
работа итальянский язык это история
привлекательный он такой легкой
фонетической и какая-то и мелодично она
помогает войти человеку нырнуть туда а
потому нужно начинать там
разворачиваться
то есть не отвращает например очень
часто те кто немецкий например начинают
учить им тяжело и они не понимают
особенно у нас видимо исторические
какие-то вещи тут имеет значение но
очень тяжело и он вроде как и нельзя
сказать что он популярный но очень много
людей в учат прежде всего для работы и
но приходит тому кому нужна некоторым
приходится заставлять шанс
он не отвечает такой же любовью вот
советский язык тебя обнимает сразу вам
как-то тебя заводит свои замаливает и
буквально ты уже там открытость языка и
тоже очень важно потому что когда ты
протягиваешь кому-то руку очень важно
чтобы тебе тоже протянули в ответ в
итальянский всегда как-то для всех
открывается сразу в этом его
привлекательность мне каж
дана надо искать тебя cifre например
немецкие культуре
которые привлекательна не не надо чтоб
всё стало привлекать или возможно надо
искать что-то музыка может быть или
история или что-то надо искать я еду для
меня когда я начать ручки количество и
качество ручки
аудиокниги и это же финский советский
жестокий романс о какой игре и в этом
фильме тоже исторические реалии костюмы
и исторического культуры сейчас
по-испански и по-русски французский
фильм который мы можем использовать это
изучение языка fling мы можем
импортировать
до дня ногу чтобы изучать из youtube
стал намного я когда я начинал за
итальянский я использую много
аудиокниги из-за и narrator и знаешь и
саратове
я знаю его
да но количество и качество не
сравнивать с ресниц по русски есть сами
раз раз опа раз есть по шведский
по-немецки много высококачественный одет
не почему арабский имеет
я просто знаю почему даже в российской
культуре до всегда было свойственно было
была такая большая столько досоветский
период
аудио спектаклей актеры например запись
всегда использовали актер драматического
театра записывали дня
огромная коллекция детских пластинок с
участием знаменитых актеров и до сих пор
продолжать эта традиция актеры и это
здорово я думаю искусство
спектакль или очень-очень украинская по
украински я искал немного аудиокниги по
украински белье и что интересно но много
нет не очень много к сожалению да вот у
нас хотя в принципе это можно было бы
сделать на просто наверное пока еще
как-то не приходят в голову чтобы люди
дать те же актеры и те же и те же люди
до культур могли записывать украинские
книги для детей и для взрослых и для тех
кто хочет изучать украинский язык для
иностранцев
прекрасное было бы называется а бук это
может искать украинские обе книги и
когда я был в киеве а там был шок нижние
книжные
да я там был один для
где находится
ну сейчас я занимаю пешком и и арабским
потом опять украинский язык я учу ли не
учусь стих можно задать вопросы ну
нельзя давать вопроса по поводу этих
маленьких я называю их маленькие языки
хотите эти верьте хотите нет но
буквально последнюю неделю я мне
обратился обратилась девушка которая
хочет включить грузинский очень девушка
которую хочет учить каталанский потому
что ее кожа rail nation
и у нее нет выхода и кроме того сегодня
мне написал женщина которая хочет очень
ее дети должны учить испанский вот и все
это в общем то маленькие языки кроме
того из 3
мирослава индивидов для него это япония
с которой приехал в грузию живет тбилиси
и как его приглашают на телевидении
грузинской чтоб он по-грузински
рассказывал его ну че ты грузин
японскому ну то есть мне кажется что
зачастую это связано с культурой люди
встречаются с культурой страны либо они
поехали в сторону влюбились
часто влюбляются в парня девушку это
тоже мать его заявляет его учить языки
работа может быть вот интересно что одно
из преимуществ малых языков это такой
секретный код то есть допустим если я
скину по английски то велика вероятность
что меня поймут те кто у кого них ряда я
говорю с кем-то по
и японский хоть это большое тоже язык но
тем не менее намного меньше цикличен я
когда-то я помню когда мастера вас
встретились с тобой стив в киеве
я тогда попросил добавить два языка
blink и это было хинди и
это был тибетский
это сказал что с тибетским это очень
вряд ли но хинди это большой на самом
деле язык это миллиарда людей которые на
нем говорят ну я хотел в этой связи
спросить какие какие вообще планы у
ленка добавлять как можно больше как за
кошки всем чтобы это стало самым большим
ресурсом языков в интернете как это
пойдет дальше конечно чтобы предлагать
язык надо иметь содержание если я
приезжаю в ли чтобы изучать эстонские
нет никакого нет одельно
урок это это лень и поэтому у нас есть
минимум надо министерский и есть эту
побольше и
и мы это за независим от tearaway
который нам помогают поэтому вы нас есть
например гуджарат и нет или почему
потому что один человек белом выдирать у
нас есть белорусские потому что сергей я
не знаю как то киньте знаешь сергей
грейс знакомы но он делал пар
белорусский у нас есть дома русские люди
рад и нет ли по но я знаю что сейчас
есть волонтеров которые готовы
сказки энди будет каталонский есть
эстонский я не знаю нет никакого план
какой я есть большое количество язык
который сейчас будет после наш новый
вещи когда номер версии кончится
я думаю если 10 или побольше язык
который уже существует и не сказки или
льду ребят я не думаю да но я хочу но
конечно не надо только сказать у нас
есть на пятки и люди приезжают и там
есть отдельный невозможно надо иметь
минимум что я хотел сказать что часто из
моего личного опыта когда людям советую
что найти в клинки и так далее мне
кажется что очень большим ресурсом
сейчас становится youtube то есть как
можно больше людей делают видео субтитры
именно это можно как для таких маленьких
языков импортировать блогеров так далее
в youtube и это может стать мы называем
это контент может стать порядок для для
линки поэтому возможно именно такой в
youtube станет большинства людей они
начинают они начинают поэтому я искал
например три года назад я использовал
моде плохо и я не могу я не мог это
использовать и поэтому я нужен был
женщине марокко до
сейчас я опять пока это дорого и и и я
использовал это снова
очень хорошо очень хорошо арабский это
сложно я думаю что и там есть много
много языки когда вы там будете японский
все
все есть поэтому это стоит 10 доллар
месяц поэтому очень к сожалению как
когда я общаюсь с adizero может ли мы
используем сегодня это поделиться значит
членами нет нет нет ада всегда-всегда
это нет поэтому если даже если мы
например хотим и могу это делиться
хорошо они не дают нам использовать
часть много много много и
обычно без гипсе поэтому если мы можем
это автоматически
берут принципе все это помогает изучение
стихе прошу прощения поскольку это видео
было инициировано тобою через три минуты
заканчивается сессия у нас выбросит мы
продолжим дальше или нет или достаточно
то время как как хватит я и звери хорошо
но потому что когда нас выбросит нужно
как-то снова нам встретиться непонятно
как или мы или мы столько мы говорить но
я думаю что может быть мы можем
закончить здесь нам на наши финансы если
да то есть и еще кое-что какой-то
вопросов у меня есть вопрос тиф и малый
языки как он малый язык ты бы выучил
совсем мало
не совсем я хотел бы изучать один из
языки языки у нас в канаде и как это
сказать
engine действий один из интересных веков
одесский язык например и я я хотел это
иметь в линьки но сложно сложно
материала наверное а маури будет мария и
у вас получается такой мини земной шар
до собранный потому что огромное вот это
слово глобализация которая саду кто кого
то пугает кто-то рад но на самом деле
миф действительно и благодаря интернету
благодаря возможности общения стал
настолько маленькие и и тут мы можем
понять вот эту модель мира до
сконструированы при помощи языка я это
потрясающе совершенно потому что это это
все равно общность даже если люди учат и
разговаривают на разных языках
они все равно таким образом связываются
друг с другом и связаны друг с другом
глобализация это неизбежно глобализации
и как глобализировать это любой вопрос и
это хорошо мы можем общаться я так думаю
очень вкусно все украине вкусно вкусно
да спасибо
[музыка]